I was wondering if you saw this tweet
from Magnus yesterday that he was
celebrating like 10th anniversary of
winning the world championship title and
he also published this photo where he
jumped inside of the swimming pool fully
I mean with his clothes on and so Fabby
at the moment when you become the world
champion what are you going to do what
is the craziest thing you are you will
do let's agree from now oh wow the
craziest thing I don't know I can't uh I
can't say yet I think this has to be
spontaneous right yes maybe but but um
if if I I don't think it's like when
because I think it's more if but if I
become world champion someday then uh
then definitely I'll do something crazy
but I'm not sure yet let's keep it
spontaneous